who are some of the artists beside your
boy Moz that you're trying to sign that
you're [ __ ] with out of your city
Jose Bodega
um
who we guys who else we got out there uh
Little Mac he's gonna go crazy I know
for sure my eyes Jose both there you go
back for sure we gonna We gonna [ __ ]
with them yeah
shout out to uh your guy mobs what's the
name of the label uh PMG PMG yeah PMG NT
I see you got you got a tattooed yeah
you got a few record labels is this just
two record labels tattooed on your arms
that's cash money you got no limit Cash
Money UGK rap a lot ruthless records you
got the ruthless tattoo yeah I got bad
boy I got NWA you just got the rap arms
trillion T death row
uh seeing me that's pretty [ __ ] I got
bwa
I think I got CMG I got a lot of
[ __ ] over here
shout out to uh Kevin Gates yeah you got
you and Kevin Gates got a close
relationship yeah that ain't crazy
that's my guy though he's an interesting
guy yeah yeah he's intense he's my guy
me and him had a great interview
recently and you know we had that one
interview that went viral a few years
ago where my co-host DJ had touched his
arm oh you remember that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah he was so [ __ ] right he was
like yo don't touch me but he just got
out so it was just it was just it was it
was a lot it was very it was a very
heavy situation and uh we cleared it up
a few months ago and had an amazing
conversation yeah but he's a unique
individual for sure ruthless records
were you with Bone Thugs-N-Harmony fan
you're of course easy for sure easy to
eat Bone Thugs I got I got an easy 10 on
my leg too but I got I ain't got on
those shorts I got on these uh jogger
pants but I got a lot of people uh
telling on my leg I mean you're paying
homage
um if you had to give me your like uh
top five all-time rappers
PMC
juvenile
Bun B Scarface
um
what if we just combine UGK that's one
slot okay yeah we can do that then what
are we gonna say so you get one more
okay
UGK juvenile juvenile I mean juvenile
um Scarface
uh
of course I gotta go easy easy even
though he didn't write his own raps yeah
so it's like cute
I I didn't say pocket bigger because
everybody say pocket big I appreciate
that yeah everybody say pocket everyone
says biggity Jay-Z little way then you
got us me too uh boosting whatever
um yeah shout out to boozy hey
um Boosie is also somebody who I feel
like when they say don't meet your
heroes or don't meet celebrities because
they'll disappoint you because they'll
be [ __ ] or they won't be who you
think they are not the case with boozy
you hang out with boozy and you're like
what he's even more hilarious in real
life this motherfucker's hilarious
um yeah boozy and Webby they gotta do I
heard them talking about doing it um
like getting back together and do
something yeah
it's been Webbie don't get enough love
also maybe a little crazy shout to
weapon yeah
whatever whatever for sure like he don't
get enough credit I I don't think like
outside the South you do but that [ __ ]
hard no web is crazy being hard 100 you
don't have a like a Jay-Z or Eminem in
there though
I'm not gonna lie like growing up I kind
of like was a big South here right I
could tell yeah but I did love listening
to like Bone Thugs Do or Die [ __ ] like
that dude I was crazy yeah and they were
on rap a lot yeah do or die that PO pimp
and [ __ ] that whole album yeah I [ __ ]
with them too but I ain't gonna lie
shout out to Chicago Midwest [ __ ] we we
got down with real UGK heads what's your
favorite UGK album come on man riding
dirty okay I gotta ask gotta know that I
mean you gotta know murderer murderer is
like one of my favorite
I mean that's to me like quintessential
if you're gonna say Bun B is one of the
goats you just press play on that come
on that's one of the best I told him
that [ __ ] like a couple months ago I
forgot what song he thought but I said I
think he's got to be out of murder one
of your best verses ever end on big
panther that's one of your of course
best versus iconic but
that murder record is yeah I think I
told him I think he was saying like the
uh the um what uh what did you say big
pimping I don't know though but that
murdered that [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] another king of moving
oh that gotta be I don't see how that's
that's not one of the top albums in the
world like the uh it's to me it's
probably one of the I mean 2400 degrees
should be one of the two of the top both
classic for sure